JEOPARDIZES THE G.O.P.'S NEW
MIDTERM MOMENTUM.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE" ."
DESPITE WHAT YOU HEAR FROM THE
MEDIA AND THE LEFT, THE
PRESIDENT AND THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY ARE WINNING ON THE ISSUE
OF IMMIGRATION.
A MAJORITY OF AMERICANS SUPPORT
TIGHTER BORDER ENFORCEMENT, ARE
AGAINST, BY THE WAY, EVEN
INCREASES IN LEGAL IMMIGRATION,
AND SUPPORT DEFUNDING SANCTUARY
CITIES.
CHECK THIS OUT, EVEN IN
CALIFORNIA A NEW UC BERKELEY
POLL FINDS THAT 59% OF
CALIFORNIANS SAY IT IS VERY, OR
SOMEWHAT IMPORTANT TO INCREASE
DEPORTATIONS OF ILLEGALS.
MUSIC TO MY EARS.
A FULL 49% SUPPORT TEMPORARILY
BANNING PEOPLE FROM MAJORITY
MUSLIM COUNTRIES FROM ENTERING
THE UNITED STATES.
THAT GOES EVEN FURTHER THAN
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TRAVEL BAN
FROM JUST SIX MAJORITY MUSLIM
COUNTRIES.
DID I MENTION THAT'S CALIFORNIA?
DETERMINED TO FULFILL HIS
CAMPAIGN PROMISES AND FOCUS ON
AMERICANS FIRST, THE PRESIDENT
URGED CONGRESS ON CAPITOL HILL
TODAY AS THEY HAVE SINCE TAKEN
OFFICE TO TIGHTEN IMMIGRATION
RESTRICTIONS.
>> WE ARE CALLING ON CONGRESS TO
SECURE OUR BORDERS, SUPPORT OUR
BORDER AGENTS, STOP SANCTUARY
CITIES, AND SHUT DOWN POLICIES
THAT RELEASE VIOLENT CRIMINALS
BACK INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE DON'T WANT IT ANY LONGER.
WE'VE HAD IT.
>> Laura: THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAVE HAD IT.
IT'S ABOUT TIME WE END THE OLD,
TWISTED APPROACH OF CATCH AND
RELEASE AT THE BORDER.
FOR ALL YOU COMMON SENSE VOTERS
OUT THERE, THIS GET TOUGH
APPROACH MAKES PERFECT SENSE.
THE GRASSROOTS, I THINK THE
MAJORITY OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IS MORE UNIFIED THAN EVER BEHIND
THIS AGENDA OF THE PRESIDENT.
SO LEAVE IT TO A SMALL, LIBERAL
BAND OF REPUBLICANS TO TRY TO
SPLINTER THE PARTY JUST BEFORE
THE MIDTERM ELECTION.
BEAUTIFUL.
BY THE WAY, OVER DACA, OF ALL
THINGS.
IT TURNS OUT THAT AT LEAST 18
REPUBLICANS, YOU SEE THE GALLERY
THERE, HAS SIGNED SOMETHING
CARD, CALLED A DISCHARGE
PETITION.
IF IT WOULD ESSENTIALLY GIVE THE
DEMOCRATS AND A FEW LIBERAL
REPUBLICANS RUN OF THE HOUSE
FLOOR AND THE ABILITY TO BRING
SEVERAL IMMIGRATION BILLS TO A
VOTE, INCLUDING A BILL GRANTING
AMNESTY TO THE DACA KIDS.
NORMALLY A DISCHARGE PETITION IS
LAUNCHED BY THE OPPOSITION
PARTY.
IT REQUIRES 218 SIGNATURES TO
ENGAGE.
SO IN THIS CASE 25 REPUBLICANS
AND ALL THE DEMOCRATS WOULD NEED
TO BE IN FAVOR TO SUPPORT IT.
SO CNN IS REPORTING TONIGHT, BY
THE WAY, THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE
THE NUMBERS FOR THE PETITION BUT
THE LAWMAKERS COULD PROVIDE NO
EVIDENCE TO THAT FACT.
THE PECULIAR THING HERE IS THAT
THE DISCHARGE PETITION AGAIN WAS
LAUNCHED BY REPUBLICANS AS A
CHALLENGE TO G.O.P. LEADERSHIP
AND OF COURSE TO THE PRESIDENT.
FLORIDA REPUBLICAN CARLOS
CURBELO, NOTORIOUS OPEN BORDERS
REPUBLICAN, THE PRIME MOVERS.
BUT THE PETITION HAS BEEN SIGNED
BY OTHERS AS WELL, INCLUDING,
UNBELIEVABLY, UTAH'S NEIL LOVE.
WILL HURD OF TEXAS.
MARIO DIAZ BULLARD AND --
CHARLIE DENT OF PENNSYLVANIA
WHOSE VOTES DON'T COUNT EVEN
THOUGH HE'S ALREADY RESIGNED.
FRED UPTON OF MICHIGAN.
DAVID REICHERT OF WASHINGTON.
COLORADO'S MIKE KAUFMAN.
CHRIS COLLINS.
BILLY STEFANIK OF NEW YORK AND
MARK ON MONDAY OF NEVADA.
NEW YORK'S CONTACT GOAT IS ALSO
CONSIDERING SIGNING
THESE REPRESENTATIVES SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES AT THIS
POINT.
COME ON.
BY DEFYING THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
THE WHITE HOUSE, WHAT DO THEY DO
THE WHITE HOUSE, WHAT DO THEY D
DO?
THEY DEMORALIZE THE BASE OF THE
G.O.P. AND THEY WEAKEN UNITY
BEFORE THE MIDTERM ELECTION.
SO RATHER THAN KEEPING A FOCUS
ON THE ECONOMY THAT IS BOOMING,
THESE REPUBLICANS HAVE DECIDED
IT'S IN THEIR POLITICAL INTEREST
TO TURN THE SPOTLIGHT TO
IMMIGRATION AND THE DACA KIDS.
WHO CARES IF IT MEANS HANDING
OVER POWER TO THE OPPOSITION TO
DO IT.
ON THURSDAY, SPEAKER RYAN
REACTED TO THIS DISCHARGE
PETITION UPRISING DURING A PRESS
CONFERENCE.
>> WE NEVER WANT TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO THE MINORITY.
AND WHAT I DON'T WANT TO DO IS
HAVE A PROCESS THAT JUST ENDS UP
WITH A VETO.
WE ACTUALLY WANT TO SOLVE THE
DACA PROBLEM.
GOING DOWN A PATH AND HAVING
SOME KIND OF SPECTACLE ON THE
FLOOR THAT RESULTS IN A VETO
DOESN'T SOLVE A PROBLEM.
THAT IS WHY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO COME UP WITH
A SOLUTION THAT THE PRESIDENT
CAN SUPPORT.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT
ALREADY OFFERED SOMETHING IN THE
DEMOCRATS SAID NO TO IT LAST
FEBRUARY.
COME ON.
WASTING TIME.
IT'S NOT UP TO A MINORITY OF
REPUBLICANS WHOSE VIEWS, BY THE
WAY, DID NOT PREVAIL IN THE 2016
ELECTION CYCLE TO NOW AT THIS
POINT TRY TO RESET THE NATIONAL
DEBATE ON DACA.
IT'S ABSURD.
IF THEY WANT TO DO SOMETHING TO
ACTUALLY HELP AMERICA, WHAT THEY
SHOULD DO IS URGE SOME MORE
MODERATE DEMOCRATS TO HELP
REFORM, LET'S SAY, THE ASYLUM
PROCESS THAT IS BEING ABUSED
TODAY BY ILLEGALS.
YOU KNOW THAT ASYLUM
APPLICATIONS HAVE INCREASED BY
1700% OVER AN EIGHT YEAR PERIOD
ALONE?
I WONDER WHY THAT'S HAPPENING.
AT A MOMENT -- NOUN HAS THE
GENERIC BALLOT TIGHTENING FROM A
PREVIOUS 13-POINT ADVANTAGE FOR
DEMOCRATS TO BASICALLY WITHIN
THE MARGIN OF ERROR, BASICALLY A
DEAD HEAT NOW.
THIS IS NOT THE MOMENT TO
DISTRACT VOTERS FROM THEIR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY, THE ECONOMY
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY, THE ECONOM
ECONOMY.
TO ALLOW THIS DISCHARGE DACA
PETITION TO PROCEED COULD BE A
MIDTERM TURNOUT KILLER, AND IT
WILL SPLINTER THE PARTY.
FOCUS ON THE THINGS THAT ARE
WORKING IN THE THINGS THAT WILL
WIN YOU THE MAJORITY IN
NOVEMBER.
KEEP THE MAJORITY.
JOBS, WAGES, SAFETY, AND YES,
POCKETBOOK ISSUES.
SO IF YOU ARE UPSET LIKE I AM
ABOUT WHAT THESE LIBERAL
REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO PUSH,
CALL YOUR CONGRESSMAN, CALL YOUR
CONGRESSWOMAN, TELL THEM HOW YOU
FEEL ABOUT THIS.
THIS PARLIAMENTARY STUNT WILL
NOT GO DOWN WELL WITH THE G.O.P.
BASE, I CAN TELL YOU THAT RIGHT
NOW.
MY RADIO LINES WERE RINGING OFF
THE HOOK TODAY.
YOU WOULD THINK, BY THE WAY,
THAT REPUBLICANS -- JUST BACK UP
FOR A MOMENT, WOULD LEARN THEIR
LESSON AT THIS POINT AFTER THAT
DISASTROUS 2007 BUSH-McCAIN
AMNESTY.
THAT WENT DOWN IN FLAMES.
A LOT OF US AND TALK RADIO WERE
UP IN ARMS ABOUT THAT AND LEAD
THE REVOLT AGAINST THAT.
AND AFTER THE DISASTROUS 2013
SCHUMER-RUBIO GANG OF EIGHT
FIASCO, THAT AMNESTY BEHEMOTH
WAS SO BAD EVEN RUBIO HIMSELF
DISOWNS IT NOW.
AT LEAST HE LEARNED HIS LESSON.
REPUBLICANS AS THE PARTY IN
POWER HAVE A REAL CHANCE TO
BREAK THE MIDTERM ELECTION
CURSE, NOT LOSE MANY SEATS,
MAYBE NOT LOSE ANY, MAYBE EVEN
PICK UP A FEW SEATS, BUT ONLY IF